[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
dark
Brandon Rises
oh my god
oh I feel like people yesterday doubted
me
Joe Biden would want these little
[__] idiots up throw them in the
trash
well he didn't disappoint of course
Old Uncle Joe did not disappoint and
neither did the Republicans to be quite
Frank oh my God their reactions
their cartoon character-ish
reactions
did not disappoint
in the moment there was a lot of moments
left a lot of moments
last night but one of the most
significant moments
was when Joe Biden got the entire
Republican conference in front of the in
in front of the American people on
National Television
to unanimously agree
full consent
that axing up Social Security and
Medicare Medicaid and taking
benefits away from the American people
in which they pay for and earn is off
the table they cannot negotiate that
point anymore now
will they continue to lie of course they
will they are Republicans this is the
party of George Santos
they're gonna [__] lie
of course they will
but
their Quest
to default on the country's debt and not
increase the debt ceiling just got that
much harder
because last night the big moment
was when Republicans stood with
Democrats to cheer Joe Biden
that's right you've heard me say it and
that's how you should say it
the Republicans stood with Democrats to
cheer Joe Biden
that under his presidency
for the full eight years that he will
have two terms he will not
cut Social Security Medicare and
Medicaid
and they know that he won't so they
won't even attempt it
is what happened
and there was a lot of other moments
last night one on our thumbnail
Marjorie hooffoot green
decides to wear some crazy [__]
costume you know it's really funny how
the right wing freaks out about people
dressing up in costumes devil costumes
at that
dancing around performing making fools
out of themselves and they think it's
some kind of demonic
hypnotism that they're trying to do on
our children and and Marjory David Green
literally dresses up as Cruella Deville
Cruella Deville devil devil
oh [__] you can't make this [__] up
dresses as Cruella Deville
no question in my mind that was her
intention
and then Kirsten Cinema did you see the
what the [__] was that thing someone
said it looked like um
Tucker Carlson lost his bow tie and it
landed on Kirsten Cinema
I don't know I don't know anything about
fashion to be quite honest with you I
don't know I don't [__] know that's
why I don't
criticize
what the [__] someone wants to dress up
and wear a costume or
I don't know I just I don't I don't get
fashion I don't get it can you tell can
you tell him that you know anyways
I don't know what the hell that was the
dress it was weird but I mean hey
whatever floats your boat
I mean obviously Kirsten Cinema wanted
to end up on the internet
I mean that's was obvious and as well as
Marjorie Taylor foot green
oh Marge DeVille
holy [__] of course she had the antic
with the balloon
later you know earlier on in the day
after we got off the air here yesterday
she she walked around the halls of the
Capitol with a with a white balloon
oh [__] these clowns they're just
they're just [__] circus clowns
and this is their leadership too by the
way it shouldn't like Marjorie tether
Green in the last Congress where she had
no committee
Authority she was basically not even
representing her constituents in Georgia
because she couldn't do anything besides
go to the floor
and now she's walking around because she
owns Kevin McCarthy's nut sack
with a [__] balloon around Congress
and dressing as Cruella Deville
and yelling and screaming at the
president while he's giving the State of
the Union as if it makes her look cool
it doesn't Marge makes you look like a
[__] idiot
every time
and every single time you people do this
and really there's another reaction that
people are
um talking about today which is Mike
Lee's reaction
they got really confused about this
social security thing they got real
[__] confused
they're almost as confused about whether
they you know like drag shows or not
they're really [__] confused about
this stuff
Mike Lee's sitting there going well I I
never said we I see he I really honestly
I think Mike Lee is disappointed
you know a lot of people want to say
that he was trying to act like he never
said that I think he's disappointed
that Joe Biden didn't name him I think
Mike Lee is proud that he wants to
[__] tear down our social safety net
that hard-working Americans pay for
stop calling him [__] entitlements
they pay for those [__] the
American people pay for Social Security
Medicare and Medicaid you
vile
succubus
stop Quantum entitlements that's they're
not that
anyways
Mike Lee sees them as that they he sees
them
as welfare
and a way for people not to work now
it's called Medicare and so it's called
retirement dummy it's called they did
work like you have to work to earn
Social Security Medicare you have to or
you have to be handicapped to the point
or or disabled to the point to where you
can't work
and we take care of you in this country
like I don't know
like we're decent humans and stuff like
we just don't leave our fellow
countrymen out in the cold
because they have a disability we
shouldn't
it's really not complicated Mike Lee but
Mike Lee I think he's disappointed in
that moment he's really pissed off that
Joe Biden didn't name him because Joe
Biden said while this little exchange
was going on last night during the State
of the Union
he said I'm politely not naming names
I'm not pointing fingers
on purpose is basically what Joe Biden
was saying because they were really
upset oh you son of a [__] you're
pointing out you're pointing out things
that are true you [__] like
that's that was their entire reaction
of the lot of them were like oh you
dirty bastard I can't believe you'd
point out the truth you [__] and of
course Joe Biden points out that hey
it's not it's not an official part of
your platform and it's not an official
party position but we know why it's not
Hello because it's it's really [__]
unpopular to take away benefits from
from people who paid for them and worked
for them you [__] scumbags
Medicare and Social Security are not
entitlements
the American people work and earn them
and the Republican Party fundamentally
wants to take that away I don't give a
[__] if it's their official party
position or not
if it's not their official party
position then they should speak out
against the members who continue to want
to do it
and who continue to support policies
that would undermine
those earned benefits for Americans to
retire
in in in their aged retirement you
[__]
as if Americans don't earn Social
Security and Medicare [__] you [__] off
but Mike Lee I think was pissed because
Biden didn't name him
right
I mean he's get caught in this [__]
situation where he told
when he was campaigning for Senator this
last time this last cycle he told a
bunch of people at a restaurant
and a campaign event that he was gonna
[__] pulled up by the roots and get
rid of it all together
and of course he made sure because it
was an old a bunch of old [__]
sitting there who were on Medicare and
Social Security who earned it
they're like I'm not talking about you
I'm not talking about you I mean you'll
be dead soon I'm talking about the next
[__] that earned it and paid
for it and worked for Social Security
Medicare I want to take it away from
them because I want more money in my
donor's pockets
because the last the less money we have
to pay corporations and businesses have
to pay
better better
if we can get rid of that employment tax
let's do that [__] them
matter of fact
let's just get rid of all
employment protection all together [__]
them
and they're like yeah woohoo
great I'll be dead what do I give a [__]
and then Mike Lee last night he's like
who said dad who said that
of course the internet's forever uh Mike
Lee doesn't understand that he doesn't
understand that in a moment that nor
does Kevin McCarthy understand this
uh some of the key moments uh are when
Kevin McCarthy doesn't clap and doesn't
go like oh yeah it's a good thing that's
a good thing uh particularly when Joe
Biden mentions that unemployment is the
lowest it's been in 50 [__] years
Kevin McCarthy's like uh God damn what
an accomplishment that you have that we
want you [__]
I can't clap for for record employment
and they all did they all sat there and
were pissed off
that right now there's record employment
that that that is a badge
that Joe Biden can wear
and dark Brandon's gonna use against
them in the 2024 election because he's
running folks I told you yesterday
[__] running [__]
running and there ain't gonna be anyone
that's going to challenge him
doubt me on this and stop talking about
it I heard it this morning on the
[__] well it's clear that Joe Biden's
gonna Wren but a poll says there's a
poll out there that says what I want to
hear so let's talk about it
there's a poll that says the American
people don't want Joe Biden get the [__]
out of here with that nonsense yeah
maybe maybe people don't want him to do
it but he's doing the job
and he did a damn good job last night at
laying that out and really there's no
one better than Jill Biden who lays this
out even Barack Obama as great as an
orator as he is Barack Obama sometimes
it can seem contrived or like his nose
is in the air that's why they [__]
call that's why this elitist thing
continues to be a narrative about
liberals which Liberals are not elitist
Liberals are for freedom and opportunity
not for only for a few but for the
equality and Equity of everyone and
using democracy as its tool to do that
it's what Liberals are for in this
country
true liberals you know you might
identify as something else you know a
Democratic Socialist or moderate or an
individ whatever the [__] you want to
call yourself but if you identify as a
liberal I'm almost damn sure that you
want freedom opportunity Choice equity
and equality in the in the in the with
the vehicle of democracy to try to
deliver that even as tough as it is
but Joe Biden does a masterful job at
laying this out for the American people
he started to talk and I've talked about
this a lot on this show he started to
talk about uh school children and
children starting school at three
instead of five right that I I say it
all the time I've been saying it for a
year and a half
the bill back better someone knocked me
the other day on the bill back better
bill I don't know they were like oh
you're so wrong about the language on
that [__] you
yeah that's right if you're my audience
and you're listening and and you want to
get in the comments and say some snarky
[__] I'm gonna be snarky back because
frankly I'm correct on the bill back
better bill that it was that it was
shitty delivery on the messaging the
bill the bill had fantastic pieces of
policy in it
it would have gave the American people a
leg up
particularly with the child the child
tax credit the monthly income that would
have been received to American parents
to make sure that children in this
country aren't living in poverty and
it's based on income not difficult to do
not really difficult even Mitt Romney
which we have news about Mitt Romney
agreed with and it was actually his
program won out over Joe Biden's in that
bill to be renewed from the original
inaction of it in the coveted relief
funds
but the buildback better bill was made
as some sort of infrastructure Bill
human infrastructure and a really dumb
it should have been an education bill
but the moment that Joe Biden during the
the State of the Union speech
started to talk about preschool he did
not go back and listen to it Go rewind
the tape and listen to that little
section I don't know that's like two
minutes long when he's talking about
education and Early Education
he does not say the word Universal
very important very [__] important in
the narrative in the messaging he does
not say the scary word the word that
scares all Republicans and all the white
Christian nationalists oh Universal
that's socialism he did not say that
word
it's very [__] important it's fair I
know it doesn't seem
like that's important but that's
important verse 2024 campaign
it's [__] important it is a clear
sign it is a clear sign that that Joe
Biden is listening to people like me and
you
he is listening they're listening
to what the message is and what not for
the message to be
he learned his lesson when Bernie
Sanders
tried to run on Medicare for all and the
Democratic party and the Democratic
primary rejected it
full-throated rejected Medicare for all
the phrasing of it
that just the phrasing you have to
understand that in politics messages
everything
it's everything
99.9 percent of it is messaging
it really doesn't even matter who
carries the message
and until we as liberals in this country
or moderate Independence Democratic
Socialist whatever the [__] you
Progressive whatever the [__] you want
to call yourself look if you're a
pro-democracy you're a [__] liberal
maybe large L maybe small L but you're a
[__] liberal if you're for a
democracy
but us as liberals in this country have
to [__] get our heads wrapped around
this idea that we have to use a certain
type of messaging
and we had to drive the narrative in the
direction that we want it to go like I
don't know children starting school at
three instead of five it kind of makes
sense it makes sense
it gives it gives families in this
country a better opportunity for their
children to be educated at an earlier
age it relieves the cost of daycare for
two [__] years on American families
by making sure that there's a portion of
the day
that is designed to educate children at
three and four
to make sure we get two extra years of
education
so that when they reach 18 and they
reach College age or they reach tech
school age or they join the workforce
that they've had two more years of full
education not only that not only that we
should [__] give them nutrition
across the board I don't care income I
don't care well I don't give a [__] if
you're in a public school you get to eat
to think that nutrition isn't part of
education is [__] bone-headed it's
like driving around a school bus without
wheels just doesn't make any [__]
sense
these are things we should be doing
but we have to talk about these things
in a way that America understands
and they understand
very easily if you don't you stupid
[__] language
that the Republicans have designed and
used their narrative and use their
messaging to make people scared of it
white folks in particular
uneducated white folks that's another
great residual thing that happens with
more education is more people are I
don't know
easier to rational thinking logic
but I ain't digress from that um
speaking of the Mitt Romney moment
Mitt Romney and
[Laughter]
the Republican leader George Santos
um they had words I guess yeah there was
a little bit of an exchange we'll watch
uh some of the tape on that there's a
bad lip readers video but it's actually
should be called a good lip readers
video just because it's
I think it's almost the exact words that
were said and then there's uh tape the
the clip of Mitt Romney describing the
conversation in the interaction
afterwards is great
uh but also in the news speaking of
reactions Sarah Huckabee Sanders
uh gave the Republicans official
response to the State of Union and she
fell flat on her ugly face excuse me her
face sorry about that
um
well look what are you gonna do with
Sarah Huckabee Sanders she's really
upset that their culture wars aren't
working so much so that she's trying to
blame people who don't give a [__] about
the culture wars that the Republicans
want to have on lgbtq people and people
of color
well average people don't give a [__]
don't give a [__] who you marry who you
love they don't give a [__] if you at if
you want to go to a drag show and have
fun maybe have a few drinks watch some
entertainment they don't give a [__]
[__] where you come from
what your religion is
well your nationality they don't give a
[__] sure Huckabee Sanders though is
blaming the culture wars
on on on the people who don't give a
[__] about the culture wars that they
want to have
well so that was the main takeaway from
Sarah Huckabee Sanders other than that
was just [__] just blather
um the real response the real Republican
response that we're going to watch today
that I think
um really everyone should be talking
about today is the one from Grandpa
Poopypants holy delusional [__] oh my
God this tape is [__] great and we've
been here at the Tony Tony Michaels
podcast we've loved that uh Liz
Harrington and some others have really
been listening to our critiques uh the
grandpa poopy pants's campaign uh
production and his uh content production
he's been taking our tips and boy boy
does did that crazy pay off holy [__]
you gotta see this I I a lot of people
aren't talking about this but I am and
the reason why this is so important who
gives a [__] what Sarah Huckabee Sanders
says at this point right who gives a
[__] she'll never be president she it's
already proven because she gave the
[__] Republicans response so she'll
never be president that's for damn sure
anyone who ever gives a [__]
Republican response to it to a
Democratic president State of the Union
Address
never becomes president never will
become president I I think that's kind
of the point I don't know
um but Sarah Huckabee Sanders is lost in
in her [__] delusion but Grandpa
poopy pants he's gonna be the nominee
folks I don't I don't know if you
watched
but I'm also gonna show
uh his war on Ron desantos and the Civil
War that's going on in Florida holy [__]
he's gone he's calling Rhonda Santos a
[__] pedo this is incredible and he's
using Midas Touch
uh uh uh news that they released about
Rhonda Santos during the campaign of
to do it it's [__] it's it's you just
can't make this [__] up you just can't
make this [__] up that he that he
absolutely has a full-on assault and
calls Ron DeSantis a pedophile and then
that Knight gives this delusional
[__] quote rebuttal to Joe Biden's
State of the Union speech it is
masterfully masterfully dumb it is
masterfully stupid and it is going to
haunt him for months and months to come
and Ron DeSantis is in trouble
because Donald Trump has crowned himself
the candidate the nominee the king of
the Republican party and it's going to
cause a lot of problems uh for them
going into the future and I mean that's
my take on it
and that's the take that I think matters
here at the attorney Michael's podcast
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch also
simulcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page we've got our own Facebook
page so go follow it if you're on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels you can
also follow us on the upwire YouTube
channel just go to the up wire the
upwire.com
it's a great new uh content creators
Channel where you can see all sorts of
commentators and and creators over there
with different takes on on today's news
also follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod download every single
episode on Apple Spotify and Google and
I would be derelict at my duty if I
didn't ask you to subscribe here to the
YouTube channel we're trying to get to
20 we are damn near to 14 000. we're
less than a hundred subscribers to
fourteen thousand on the road to 20.
so if you would for me please if you
have not already
subscribe to the YouTube channel do it
now even if you're on another platform
listening please go over to YouTube and
subscribe just search the Tony Michaels
podcast it'll come up we're getting more
and more popular by the minute
oh this show is growing like crazy
growing and it's because of you it's
because of you and your support and I
want to thank all the supporters over at
patreon I hope you guys are having a
good time over there on patreon I've
been trying to do some content do some
early releases of content over there I
think I'm gonna do um this weekend I'll
do sort of a weekend video for those of
you in the tier that get the uh the the
access to the exclusive content on the
weekends so go check that out
um and you can see all the announcements
and everything but it's great support
you're able to go over there and you can
direct message me over there you can
talk to me I try to respond to to most
of the comments that you make on the
post over there I like engaging over
there with you guys more it's more of a
small knit group than like elon's
Twitter which by the way
oh
he's getting bashed uh this this morning
in a congressional hearing we'll
probably watch some of that tape I know
Gabe Sanchez will be interested in
watching some of that tape in the
shitless Roundup but I do want to thank
everyone over on patreon I want to thank
all of you
because I want you to understand that
I will never gate this show whether it's
two hours or three hours I will never
get this show you will never be charged
to watch this show is my goal
as a commentator to give you as much
commentary during the week as I possibly
can and I'd like to give you three hours
two right now is feasible we want to get
the three and the patreon is only making
that more and more possible
so I want you to understand that I
appreciate everyone watching even people
who cannot afford or just don't want to
give me money I'm okay with that I'm
fine with that come give me your ears
come give me your eyes share it around
if you can but any support is support
even from you haters yeah that's right I
see you
I see you hate Watchers and I see your
your comments on Instagram and Facebook
and Twitter I know you hate me and I'm
glad you hate me so much I should come
and watch every single weekday and you
should continue to hate watch me
because love me or love to hate me I
don't give a [__] just come watch this
show Monday through Friday noon Eastern
11 Central 9 Pacific every single
weekday
on YouTube Twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page everyone stick around we
got a lot of [__] tape to go through
today oh it's beautiful it is a
beautiful day in the neighborhood stick
around we'll be right back
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
oh it's hot day
it's hump day
gotta get through the shitless Roundup
[Music]
to show you
we are definitely not gonna get to all
this these
[Music]
stupid mistakes now these uh moglodytes
and giving their opinion on the State of
the Union
including Sarah Huckabee Sanders and
Grandpa Poopypants that tape of Grandpa
poopy pants the Cheeto dusk you and
honor that tape I definitely am going to
show we have to get to that one also I
want to show you the the
um the clip of Mitt Romney and George
Santos
going at it oh my God oh maybe you do oh
man you talk about just
make me smile really all the Republican
Antics last night were [__] fantastic
oh it was fantastic the way they
responded at everything they're
predictably unpredictable I've been
telling you this I knew they'd freaked
the [__] out I knew Joe Biden would lay
it out in a way that the American people
could understand of his accomplishments
and what he accomplished what he did and
didn't do he made a fool of Republicans
it absolutely made a fool out of them
and he didn't even have to fire many
shots other than to point out they're
they're [__] lies one of the main
lies is when he was talking about a a
bridge where him and Mitch McConnell
stood at the bridge
to hand out the 1.7 billion dollars that
is going to fix that [__] bridge and
build a new one
and me and Gabe in Texas Paul and Texas
Paul brought it up we were talking about
it yesterday in Texas Paul he he
mentioned that 40 40 of our GDP goes
across that rail Bridge
and Joe Biden made sure to mention that
last night made a fool out of
Republicans
because as they were scoffing at the
fact that he went
to give that 1.7 billion dollars for
that bridge that has been promised to be
fixed
for decades including by the Cheeto dust
cue in honor when he was campaigning in
2016 more promises made and broken by
Trump
but Joe Biden dark Brandon delivers even
with Mitch McConnell at his side and the
reason why is exactly the reason why
dark Brandon mentioned last night when
he was talking about
the shovel-ready jobs
for infrastructure
because he wanted to make sure that
Mitch McConnell couldn't pass the check
without the folks there knowing
that it wasn't it wasn't Republicans who
did this
listen
there were Republicans who voted for
infrastructure
and it was a bipartisan vote
but it was not a bipartisan effort
Republicans tried their damnedest to
make sure that Joe Biden did not have
that success
be damned the American people they don't
give a [__] about the American people
they only care about their own power in
the image of it and the theater just
look at [__] Marjorie Taylor green
last night
and you need to go no further
but Joe Biden says as the Republicans
scoff at him about the infrastructure
bill
he says I'll see I'll see you at the
ground breakings
White House should make sure to reign
someone from the White House or Joe
Biden himself is at every single one
over the next few years somebody's there
to represent who [__] actually gave
the effort to get the legislation passed
for the American people in the
infrastructure bill
they're on site while they're they're
doing the whole shivel thing and passing
out checks she's seen Ron desantos down
in Florida doing this
time and time again where he's passing
out a goddamn check
that he that he was against
he was against the infrastructure Bill
speaking out against it and now he's
passing out checks acting like he's the
one who passed it but she's not even in
Congress in the first place and still
spoke out against it [__] Rhonda Santos
and Joe Biden's right they should the
Democrat should take this by the Reigns
Democrats in neighboring districts
should go
where these are where these these
infrastructure projects are being done
and accepted and taken pictures for the
press to put in the newspaper Oh look
The Republican congressman who voted
against the infrastructure who fought
for it to fail
is passing out a check to get real
internet providers in rural areas
yeah the neighboring Democratic and the
senators from those States
and neighboring states who gives a [__]
just show up show the [__] up [__] them
[__] em [__] em [__] em it's enough for
this garbage
we do not we do not have to not play
their game
we can play political theater too
I don't know why we can't why why can't
we why why is it so disgusting that we
fight for our democracy
even to politicize issues to make sure
to save it is it really that difficult
to just swallow your your [__] Pride
a little bit and go you know what
maybe we should win
maybe we should win maybe we should
gerrymander the [__] [__] out of blue
States California New York New York
Illinois
any blue State out there for that matter
should be gerrymandering the [__] out of
their districts and getting rid of
Republican districts
they should Jared Democrats and these
democrats-controlled states should be
working so hard that they get courts to
reject their districts
because they go too far that's what they
should be doing [__] [__] them you want
to play the game where you get your
minority ideology to rule in half of our
[__] legislator half of our Congress
of the United States of America you get
49 [__] senators
in the Senate when they only represent
about 25 percent of the country get the
[__] out of here with that nonsense
let's gerrymander the [__] out of these
blue States because we're not going to
get rid of gerrymandering
we're not with the Republicans in charge
you think we're gonna get rid of
gerrymanding where the Republicans in
charge the [__] out of here that's the
only way they stay in power
in our federal government in the first
place
that's the only way the only [__] way
they stay in power the only reason why
Kevin McCarthy is even the house speaker
and he was he didn't clap
behind Joe Biden when Joe Biden made
sure the American people knew that we
had record employment in this country
I'm tired of it Hearing in his record
unemployment it's record employment
record employment in this country which
is a great thing it's not far enough we
need wages to go up
we need to relieve businesses and
workers of Health Care cost you know
that's that's a whole nother thing we
what we have to do what we have to do is
gerrymander these states
that's all we gotta do [__] them if you
gerrymander blue States New York
California Pennsylvania
if you Jared Michigan now if you
gerrymander these blue States and box
out five Republican seats there you go
there's your house there's your house
majority it's not it's not reflective of
the majority of ideology in this country
but at least they have control
over the Committees and over the
legislation that gets to the floor and
maybe just maybe with someone like Joe
Biden who knows how who knows how
government works and knows how to get
[__] done even with the slimmest
majorities could get [__] done like in
we got this opportunity here to do it so
yeah and you know a lot of people are
going to knock me like oh you can't play
their game
why are you advocating for
gerrymandering when that's how they they
because they're going to do it
what don't you get what don't you
[__] understand
they will go to the end of the Earth to
force their fascism on us to force their
religion on us
to force their culture wars on us they
will go to the end of the [__]
Earth
why shouldn't we go to the end of the
Earth to defend democracy
even if we got to use it to bang them up
a little bit [__] them they want to play
the game we should play the game they're
playing
maybe maybe they'll decide to stop
playing the game
maybe they'll decide to stop playing the
game go crawl back underneath their
rocks for another 20 30 years
until it's popular again for fascism
to rear its ugly head I don't know I'm
just saying just saying oh Tony oh my
God
oh my God yours is disgusting yes they
are maybe that might be a that might be
the truth I don't know I'm not really
sure of that but I'll tell you I'll tell
you one thing I give a [__] about I give
a [__] about the Democracy surviving
that's what I give a [__] about all
right let's do this we got a lot of
video to get to I gotta stop ranting and
raving we're okay Jesus Christ we're 40
minutes into the first hour everybody
we're gonna surf the Tweety tweets and
trendy Trends watch these clips it's a
lot of [__] to round up shitless Roundup
coming right at you start the countdown
[Music]
please
[Applause]
thank you
the [__] list
welcome back to this show you've reached
part of the show we ran up all the
Tweety tweets and Trends in the [__]
let's round up and boy do we have a
ton of [__] around up today you're going
to want to put on your waiters uh Cosmo
says something here about the state of
the union says Biden wiped the floor
with all the naysayers goddamn right he
did but here's the thing here's the
thing and this is why this is why a lot
of people have been getting upset with
me
About Me Knocking
tyt and David backman
um because I know what's probably going
to happen in the commentary sphere at
first it'll be like yeah he did a great
job here's some good things that he did
but oh but those accomplishments that he
was talking about just didn't go far
enough he's not he's too old he's too
old oh my God he's too old they're gonna
say that stupid [__] all kinds of dumb
ass [__] is he really in touch with the
Merit what Americans want what America
needs
that's that's what the [__] they're
gonna say the [__] they're gonna say now
again I I I'm not in the Biden cult
right so I don't like have a flag
I don't have pictures of Hunter Biden's
[__] I don't I I never had a bumper
sticker
I didn't um I I donated to Biden's
campaign because I didn't put Trump to
win and I know money takes money uh to
do that
but I but I I don't even talk about him
a lot here the only reason why I have to
talk about him today is because
yesterday he absolutely [__] torched
them in front of the American people on
national TV and I don't even think they
[__] realized it but more importantly
what Joe Biden did last night is prove
to the Democratic party
that he's gonna be the nominee
and he he ain't going no one's gonna
[__] challenge him
no nobody
in their right mind would challenge the
president United States that is our
current president United States and the
Democratic primary no [__] chance
not gonna happen won't happen
especially after last night
and it was masterful
it was masterful and I told you
yesterday that's what was gonna happen
because the Republicans are so
predictably unpredictable thank you for
your cause comment kesmo
um
speaking of predictably unpredictable
Yeah Boy uh Mike Lee really steps in it
uh Midas touch points it out here in a
video they cut
here is uh here's Mike Lee in the
difference in what Mike Lee says behind
closed doors
and how he act like he's holding in a
fart when uh Joe Biden calls him out on
wanting to get rid
of social security by his words
pull it up by its roots that's what he
says let's listen
to what he says in private and then how
he acts in public when he gets caught it
will be my objective to phase out Social
Security to pull it up by the roots
here here
yay pull it up by its roots and get rid
of it Mike Lee last night's like whoa
whoa whoa who's this person you're
talking about that wants to destroy
earn benefits of working Americans
stop calling it entitlements they're not
entitlements they're earned benefits
that working Americans earn and pay for
it you [__] scumbags
um so Mike Lee's face let and it really
looks like and you know what it doesn't
look like he's holding in a fart it
looks like he's full-on sharded right
because this whole Social Security
cutting Medicare and getting rid of
Social Security it's going over like a
wet fart in a white thong for Mike Lee
and the Republicans
um I actually I'm I'm I really kind of
think
I really kind of think that
the reason why
um Mike Lee is a little upset in this in
the clip from last night here's why is
because Joe Biden wouldn't say his name
he was really just he's like oh man this
was my moment I was hoping you'd call me
out I was hoping I was hoping that you
would make sure that everyone knew I was
the one who wants to pull Bennett care
up by its roots and get rid of it what
do you think Gabe Sanchez do you think
he's mad because he he didn't get named
by Joe Biden specifically or because he
got caught with I don't know the
internet being forever what do you think
is the uh
uh uh I think it's more along the lines
of
him I mean because like the whole like
feigning thing is like well I never did
I just say I never said that I would
never the internet is forever like you
said but
um I honestly think at this moment
he's just [__] Hamming it up like
everybody else they're like oh no we
never said that because you've got also
Kevin McCarthy behind Joe Biden when
he's calling out Republicans and I mean
like Bravo for doing that he calls him
out for you know coming after Medicare
Social Security he calls them out for
trying to help the wealthy and not help
those in the middle class and lower
class and Kevin McCarthy sits behind and
goes
yeah he's like oh oh oh you oh you're
bragging about record employment oh
right you're bre you're bragging you're
bragging about all this stuff we don't
like we don't like but the fact that he
sat behind him and was like no no that's
not true that's false like you can
talking about the social security thing
right right also pull that can you pull
that clip find that clip because
um of his reaction of Kevin McCarthy's
reaction at this point because you're
describing the point where basically
dark Brandon gets the entire Republican
caucus to change their unofficial
position in front of the American people
that oh yeah well of course we don't
want to get rid of Social Security man
that's that's really unpopular right for
the American people as a whole so we
can't we can't any he did it so masterly
I don't actually think that Joe Biden's
intention was to do that like I don't
think he actually thought he was gonna
get him box just in this corner but when
he saw that he had them boxed in this is
the this is the Brilliance of actually
having a politician who knows politics
who's been in politics for their entire
[__] life and they know an
opportunity when they see it and the
opportunity last night that Joe Biden
had was basically to show the American
people that these people are lying to
you they're either lying to you when
they say they don't want to get rid of
the [__] earned benefit of Medicare
and Social Security or
they're lying to you when they say they
do
like like Mike Lee I believe he's in
this room and I believe when he's
talking about how he wants to pull it up
by its roots and [__] get rid of it
he's lying you gotta understand he's in
a room full of a bunch of Rich
[__] that are within a couple
of Decades of death right they don't
give a [__] about their Medicare Social
Security payment they don't give a [__]
about that measly little [__] payment
that keeps poor people out of poverty
right they don't it's no bother to me
you should see my investments I got a
yacht and three vacation homes you know
and they're clapping and he's gonna get
rid of Social Security Medicare because
those boneheads think well I'm tired of
paying taxes to support poor people like
that's their mentality right and that's
why Mike Lee is playing into that in
that room at that moment but then on the
floor of the house when he gets called
out in public he's like what no I would
never I would never do that because
these [__] are liars they're
just and they have no principle they
have no Foundation of patriotism
whatsoever they do not care about their
fellow countrymen they don't give a [__]
and it is clear with the clip that
you're going to show me with Kevin
McCarthy that he doesn't give a [__]
about the people who work their entire
[__] lives worked for the earned
benefit of Social Security and Medicare
he doesn't give a [__] and that's why
they see him as entitlements because
their Rich asses don't need them they
don't need them yeah and they just see
them as more taxes I have to pay for you
poor people the poor is always wanting
something more and that's what it is
right that's you you have a wealthy
group of people people who are making
the laws that don't want to pay their
fair share and they definitely don't
want because you know once their time in
Congress or the Senate is over
they're looking out to be like well I
don't want to be taxed out the [__]
ass for for all the money I made or all
the Investments I made because of my you
know Insider information which again is
on both sides of the aisle both people
do it it should be completely banned and
yet no one can come to an agreement no
you know
uh no surprise there but I'm searching
for this clip
but when you talk about you know they
don't they don't care about you know the
lower class because they need someone to
pass the buck off to right they need to
say well I'm not going to obey it
someone else should right and like you
need to pull yourselves up by your
bootstraps well it's hard to do that
when you're [__] six feet under in a
in a [__] pile of mud and you can't
reach the shoelaces or your boots to
like [__] pull them up you know I
don't know if this is the clip or not
but and this is one instance where Kevin
McCarthy does not the thing is like it's
hard to find them all because like he
talks about the subject but then I'm not
finding the reaction I'm looking for but
anyway here's here's one of the clips
let's listen to this and see if this is
it and two years ago democracy faces
created threats in the Civil War and
today though bruised our democracy
remains unbowed and Unbroken
so that's
that's not exactly the clip we were
looking for but it is astounding it is
astounding that the president United
States coming to the State of the Union
to tell Congress it is his job his duty
to tell Congress the State of the Union
as he sees it as the executive because
he would know all these things because
he is the are supposed to know all these
things because he is the executive but
Kevin McCarthy can't stand up and when
he says that our democracy
is as strong as it's ever been he's like
no that and if that's the truth I don't
want to clap because I want democracy to
fail like right that's the sense that
you get from that [__] scumbag the
other thing that I noticed
um
is this from the speech and I I meant to
bring this up in the first 30 minutes
but I'm glad you're here for this this
um this part of it ah I found it I found
it okay yeah just give me that one and
then I'll I'll play it after I I give
you this
um my little two cents here on the
difference because I've been talking
about what Joe Biden said but I think
comparing it because we're gonna compare
it to Grandpa poopypants's rebuttal I
don't know if you watched that video it
is I did oh my god there there he did
not write he did not write those posts
no well somebody else did well let me
tell you something they are really I
think some their producers are watching
this show because they are really taking
our advice as we give our critiques I
mean Point by Point by Point by point
it's it's you're doing a bang-up job
down there to make him look like a fool
it's fantastic
um but here's the difference in
comparison and contrast of what I saw
last night Joe Biden had a lot of we we
US America we US America
during the last four years you'd hear I
me I me Trump like that was the words
that you would hear right I bet if you
comb through Joe Biden's speech there
are very few eyes or Me's in that speech
it was all wheezing us because I think
that's one thing that makes Joe Biden
such an effective president and I'm not
talking about an order a messenger just
knowing how government works and what
his job is is that he truly at his heart
is in that office because he is old
because this is his last hurray like if
if he wins in 2024 that's it there's no
other political future for Joe Biden
that's it he he's got to go out with a
bang he understands that he is there not
for him he is not there
for for me or I he is there for we are
us he is there for the American people
and he understands fundamentally that
that is his job and yes it is a
difficult job to get everyone in this
country what they want
but he understands that and it's Court
uh you know who doesn't the guy that you
just sent me the uh the clip of Kevin oh
yeah he clearly doesn't and it's clearly
in his reactions uh again the most
astounding one to me is when he um can't
clap for record employment I'm like whoa
dude yeah how brutal is it that that the
truth of record employment makes you so
butthurt that you can't clap that that
the the a record number of Americans
have jobs which is it's a you know
because what it is is yeah it's a it's a
big win for for Biden and the policies
that he's passed during his his time as
president but also it's again it's a we
it's a win for all of us if more people
have jobs the economy does better
there you know we're trying to find
equilibrium of supply and demand and how
many jobs are available and how many of
those people are seeking work right now
as well as like you know you're
generating wealth within the economy for
those people who are working trying to
help those by increasing wages
increasing benefits making sure that
these people are taken care of
Republicans say not so fast not so fast
only some people get benefits only some
people get higher wages only some people
get taken care of right remember it is
the anti-christian anti-American way of
the Republican party which is uh you
know uh you don't get everything that I
get right like rules for me but not for
the kind of thing right and that's what
it is and you see it in these clips I
mean there are a handful of Clips where
Kevin McCarthy will not stand or clap
for the wins that are for all of us as
Americans as the United States of
America
Biden right right but I think that's
intentional because their true mindset
at this point and I think he brings it
up at one part of the speech is like
it's just fake outrage you're just
you're faking it like you're faking it
because you're mad at me and you and you
want your your Twitter followers to know
that you're mad at me and that you
disagree with me on every single point
and every single measure like you're
really stupid like you're playing into
social media just as a political game
and it's not working for you it's not
working I'm the president yep the
Democrats have the Senate you didn't
have a red wave you've lost you lost the
[__] governorships in Michigan or are
in Pennsylvania excuse me we gained we
gained the governorships in Pennsylvania
Michigan Wisconsin Arizona the same as
Secretary of States to defend our
democracy from the 2024 election of you
[__] trying to overturn it at
the state level barely got the
speakership right 15 around right I mean
I mean look Kevin McCarthy regardless of
whatever his Legacy is what he's
accomplished is he will now forever be
in the history books as the second
longest person to to take to get
nominated and elected as Speaker of the
House and then not but several weeks
later sit and not clap for the
accomplishments of the American people
because he hates the American people but
let's watch let's watch this clip our
Republican friends
want to take the economy hostage I get
it unless I agree to the economic plans
all of you at home should know what
those plans are
instead of making the wealthy pay their
Lauren bobert there someone said on the
internet last night that she looked like
um her her barbecued sliders her pork
sliders were kicking in I was just gonna
say it looks like the face you make when
you know you're about to have to [__]
your pants but you don't have an easy
route out and so you're like oh [__] I'm
[__] stuck here meanwhile Matt Gates
is giving a little corner eye which by
the way I just want to point out last
night Joe Biden came in and there was
this whole thing I don't know if anyone
followed uh uh Scott McFarland but he
was talking about how uh George Santos
was making sure that he was on the aisle
seat right in a bright orange tie so he
could shake uh Joe Biden's hand hand
right well when it came down to it
they pushed him aside he never got that
handshake in but you want to know who
did get a handshake in was it Matt Gates
Matt Gates and you want to know who he
was introduced to get a handshake from
Joe Biden
the guy who the guy okay remember during
the speaker vote I forget his he's a I
forget his name right now but the the
the representative who bent over
whispered some [__] Godfather like
[__] like into okay all that dirt that
they're talking about you and your
staffers we know it we're gonna use it
again who bent over whispered those
things into his ear said to Joe Biden
hey shake his hand all of a sudden you
see Matt Gates come over with a smile
and he [__] shook that hand and he
accepted it with a big [__] grin so
happy to see Daddy bite him you know
please get is there is there footage of
this can you find that let me see if I
can find it I might just have to get
after this
um but the other thing I want to bring
up uh here is that you see again gets
and uh Bobo the Clown sitting next to
each other and Marjorie Taylor green
sitting away from them because we know I
guess there was almost a physical
altercation between Lauren bobert and
Marjorie Taylor green I don't know if it
was over the pork sliders or the or the
little balloon that Marjorie Taylor
green was uh Pennywise [__] yeah so I I
know I'm not really sure but let's let's
finish this clip here because I do want
to say
um Kevin McCarthy is holding the economy
hostage and I want to say Joe Biden's
opportunity last night to undermine them
holding it hostage for Social Security
because now they've lost the argument
that they can that they can
fundamentally change entitlements as
they call them their earned [__]
benefits not entitlements and and they
can change entitlements and try to
change the budget that already exist for
the debt that we have to pay
um and hold the econ the economy hostage
and hold the country hostage last night
Kevin McCarthy even though he's lying
behind Joe Biden he really lost his
argument saying no no we're not no we're
not which undermines his whole plan to
actually do that thing but let's let's
give in you your fair share of some
Republicans
some Republicans want Medicare and
Social Security Sunset I'm not saying
it's a majority
so there is the scene that's what
happened
um right before Jill Biden took the
opportunity to absolutely smash up their
narrative and their messaging and and
Destroy any chance they have of using
um a budget in the title entitlement
reform it's earned benefits
um entitlement reform to hold our
country and our government and now you
know we've we've got the footage of him
because what he says there I mean like
he even he even clarifies he goes you
know Republicans want to hold the
economy hostage and they want to take
away Social Security and Medicare and
they all go and he goes not all of you
not all of you right but they're still
pissed off right wow if that means that
if something gets passed not that it
would ever get signed and and well he
says that he says that he says I would
veto right it's good that we all
unanimously agree because at one point
he's like now we all agree we can take
it off the table and he's like because I
would veto it even if he did it like so
it doesn't matter and just yeah and so
everyone understands like it would never
pass the Senate and it would never get
to the desk and he would never sign it
right they would be vetoed but that's
assuming it gets passed in the house and
then it gets passed in the Senate and
then it gets to his desk like all of
these bills that we've seen in the first
few weeks of them being in the actual
118th Congress now that they've actually
elected Uh Kevin McCarthy for whatever
small amount of time he's left uh
these things will never never get to the
desk of Joe Biden right these are all
things that are just performative oh we
fired 87 000 workers that would have
been hired right we're taking away
billions of dollar in funding that no
one's ever really actually lied used or
received yet
um it's just that's just how it is but
yeah anyway for anyone who doesn't know
that just well you're safe won't ever
get passed well here's another scumbag
that pushed this effort to absolutely
get rid of and and sunset the [__]
Sunset Medicare benefit yeah this is on
Fox news of all places I want you to
know the context here this is on Fox
News
um that this exchange is happening I'm
not sure the Anchor's name is probably
mixed scumbag or something is probably
the Anchor's name uh Johnny mix gumbag
is that his name is that his official
yeah okay okay good um but uh Johnny mix
gumbag here calls out Rick Scott but
watch this exchange on on how Rick Scott
wants to destroy your earned your earned
benefits Social Security and Medicare
recently put out an 11 point plan to
rescue America two of the big points of
which are quote all Americans should pay
some income tax It also says all federal
legislation sunsets in in five years so
that would raise taxes on half of
Americans and potentially Sunset
programs like Medicare Medicaid and
Social Security
which are all like right out there in
the open because they weren't hiding
this yeah they weren't hiding they
weren't like oh no we don't want to do
this get elected on not doing it and
then try to do it right they were they
were getting elected in 2022 to destroy
your earned benefits to destroy them and
take them away from you watch watch
though the back and forth here because
he really tries to do the thing that
Mike Lee was doing last night when he's
like oh what what what I never said that
with you guys are crazy right
but it's tough when you're on live
television let's watch
why would you propose something like
that in an election year
sure well John that's of course the
Democrat talking points in the plan
it's in the plan here's to him but
here's this thing about reality for a
second let's talk about everybody
it's not a democratic talking point it's
in the plan
and the look for Rick Scott when he's
like oh [__] it is either he did it is
like either somebody made the plan he
was like that's good just gotta check
boxes
that sounds great yeah I'll pay less
taxes you mean my donors will play less
taxes that's great that's great man you
know Rick Scott is a terrible human I've
said this before he's a human well you
know he's like a I didn't realize that's
like a like a body snatcher wait wait a
second wait a second uh breaking news
Gabe Sanchez has informed us that Rick
Scott in fact is a human I didn't yeah
I'm not I'm not I did not know that I
can't say it's 100 right 100 human but
he's somewhat human I mean I said this
before on the show I've I used to work
with his daughter yeah right uh and uh
Jordan and she [__] hated him
and he came to the office with his wife
oh my God it was [__] terrible anyway
uh Jordan was like the black sheep of
the family and uh well she was the good
one just he was the good one I mean
she's done the public appearances but
you're the black sheep of Rick Scott's
family you're you're probably you're
you're probably do you breach the bar of
decency right but she yeah she
definitely would tell me she's like oh
man like I hate that my dad's in
politics I don't agree with what he says
this and that she's public about it too
right like uh I don't know how
publishing well you just doubt it you
just yeah I just doubt it so that's fine
I mean the other thing is like she was
yeah [__] it was years ago right
statue of limitation right um but she
was and you you didn't you didn't you
didn't have a non-disclosure agreement
anyways yeah yeah it was just like open
conversation you know who knows you know
all right wow but it's just water cooler
doctors hey we're just hanging out in
the startup just just talking just it's
a startup is that yeah that's what we
were we both worked at the same story
um but yeah it's it is one of those
things where uh Rick sketch is like an
awful person and not even not even
family members at least his daughter
doesn't like him because they know that
he's a piece of [__] I mean I remember
that she worked at the company during
the time when he [__] closed down the
election polling places when it was
raining in Florida right because you
know the governor he was the governor
can you believe in 2012. they actually
elected a non-humanist governor in
Florida too same as they're doing now
they have a non-human as Governor now
um DeSantis speaking of hatred and
people who hate people and Santos holy
[__] this moment okay now this this is a
bad lip readers that the actual account
bad lip reading uh but I don't think
it's a bad lip reading like I actually
think this is almost exactly word for
word what was said uh in the exchange
between Santos and Romney now this is
the moment that you're talking about
where Santos is trying to work his way
yeah
we've got senate members coming in to
the to the chamber right now and this is
Santos trying to because right now where
he is he has edged himself on the seat
that's on the aisle right and I can't
find the clip and I'm trying to look for
C-SPAN but
um
when Biden enters he is nowhere into
frame like nowhere in the frame you
think that's because of what Mitt Romney
says here out loud and he says it maybe
but there's an interaction after he
turns around where he's still kind of
laughing with with uh with Thomas Massey
here and then also there's
[Music]
um
uh chip Roy that's right next to him as
well so I can't say for certain if they
pushed him aside or if he moved aside
but either way all I can say is that
when it came to when they came down the
aisle George Santos did not get that
shaken because I know that's what he
wanted and I know he wanted to be like
oh I said something to Joe Biden which
even if he did shake his hands I
guarantee George Santos would not say
[__] I mean yesterday he spent the whole
day avoiding the constituents who showed
up to the [__] Capital whoa wait a
second you mean you mean he hid in his
office tons of constituations from his
from his his district New York's third
he said I wanna you know even when he
said in the elevator 142 when he's meant
142 000 people who voted for him to be
in office because they were under the
idea that this was a different George
Santos please tell me they bust up 142
people please tell me they bust them
100. I wish they actually did 142. you
know how great that would be that would
be a a great burn oh yeah right that 140
like they were counting yeah like
they're like oh nope that's 100. yep if
you wanna if you want to come you need
to go across the street
so so
um now let's watch this bad lip reading
which I think actually is a good Ripley
or lip reading if you want to know the
honest truth let's watch it you ought to
be embarrassed yeah sure you ought to be
embarrassed
are you you ought to be embarrassed son
you got me
that's your opinion yes yeah you're very
formal quite a gentleman aren't you
I'm gonna say
I think that's the real lip reading that
this is like the best bad lip reading
they've ever right I was like those
words because when you watch these
sometimes like okay you know like I
could do I know that would be right
that's what I'm like it looks almost
identical right it looks like
well you know the reason why they got it
pretty close is because Mitt Romney
after the fact that reporters were like
whoa whoa what the [__] was that about
and they kind of chased him around and
he didn't he wasn't shy about it here's
what he said about their conversation
afterwards so we know kind of exactly
what the exchange was yeah
I didn't expect that he'd be standing
there trying to shake hands with every
senator in the president United States
given given the fact that he's under
ethics investigation he should be seated
on staying quiet instead of
parading in front of the president and
uh and and people coming into the room
so Mitt Romney obviously knows the
problem of George Santos uh we're trying
to Elbow his way in to shake the hands
with the president of the United States
he obviously knows the problem the one
problem that Mitt Romney knows about
because he's not I mean Mitt Romney
knows politics Jesus Christ this guy ran
for [__] president back in 2012 he
won the Primary he was their nominee he
got his ass kicked by Obama but he still
he still was their nominee and then he
went on to become the senator from Utah
so he he knows a little bit at least
about politics and and U.S politics and
more than anything imagery right Mitt
Romney understands imagery that's why
he's the only [__] that voted to
impeach Trump both times he's the only
one that did it twice and Republican
because he knows what imagery is he
understands it and he knows how history
is going to judge him Mitt Romney's not
an idiot now I'm not a Mitt Romney fan
but he's not an idiot but in this moment
I think what Mitt Romney knew about
George Santos standing there is exactly
what I've been telling the audience out
there is we do not want George Santos to
go away we do not want this story of
George Santos being an average normal
Republican he just got caught in these
lies and he's not very good at telling
them all the Republicans all of them
Senators congressmen are all elected on
lies that they tell their constituents
they tell their constituents lies to get
elected George Santos is not abnormal in
that way he told lies to his
constituents to get elected just the
lines that he told were just the
constituents feel like it's a little
scummier and he's a fraud and he's a
phony and it seems like he's a criminal
at this point we'll find out exactly
what the answer non-ethics investigation
you know say say what you will about you
know uh Mitt Romney
but I will say you know he knows so he's
like well I'm the [__] Senate I'm
never gonna have to see you ever again
right like this might be the only time
assuming that there is some sort of
outcome of the ethics investigation or
the FBI investigation into the dog scam
or the doj investigation into the
campaign Finance issues ah
um sorry I just saw a clip of uh of one
of the people that I was looking for but
um
but what I will say is Mitt Romney knew
exactly I mean one I'm sure Mitt
Romney's like I don't give a [__] but
also the second is Mitt Romney was like
I never have to work with you like I
don't have to right
we don't have to co-sponsor a bill
together we don't have to [__] I
don't have to cross my you know over the
aisle to do this or do that I don't have
to see you for the rest of my [__]
life
and that is why he would and that's why
I assume he was like you shouldn't be
here yeah because that's also I think it
also is like one of those people who's
like oh I must you know
in in some respects Mitt Romney he's
like I'm a star athlete here in the
Senate I've been around I ran for
president I did okay I did this I passed
these laws blah blah blah this whatever
and he looks at George Santos who's like
this [__] brown-nosing uh you know
guy who's trying to suck up get as much
screen time and air time and Limelight
as he can and it's just one of one of
those guys that we've all known in high
school right who tries to like
BSU to make you you know to say random
[__] that makes you feel good or
whatever but you're like you're just a
little prick who doesn't care about
anything about what you're saying you
just want to get your way into like the
cool kids which is this Republican party
that he wants to be a part of but Matt's
Mitt Romney but Romney saw for what it
is do you think the Republicans are cool
kids I'm just one no no no no I'm not
saying I'm saying I know I just circled
I'm giving you [__] now here's what
here's what I actually think that is a
deeper the deeper politics and imagery
to Mitt Romney is Mitt Romney's like
Jesus Christ this is not good for
Republicans going forward with this
imagery of the Republican caucus letting
George Santos work his way over to shake
his hand of the Senators and the
president that what should happen the
imagery that Mitt Romney wanted was
these Republicans to tell him to stay
the [__] away from the aisle you know
you're not even supposed to be here my
friend but that's the point that's the
and that's the imagery is that they
welcomed Santo oats they it's he is a
normal average everyday Republican folks
they don't see him any different as just
a PR problem that's it that's it what's
this clip that okay this is the Biden
entrance all right we're gonna follow
this
uh if you watch the clip let me just get
the name right of the guy Helen Gates
oh so this is the one where Matt Gates
is you're right yeah yeah uh
line I just want to make sure I get the
name right of this guy
oh you're talking about the one who did
The Godfather leaning and said hey he
was just he's he's sitting right now on
the oversight committee that's looking
into the legs are okay Biden laptop
um which I think if we get to some
footage we'll have Jim I don't report
sex crimes Jordan
um with some clips from the cop
committees this morning where he's uh
one clip in particular where he just
gets dunked on
um because he's a fool which I mean you
know again typical Republican so here is
here's the clip of Biden entering and
Matt gatz apparently
being very excited that he gets to shake
Uncle Joey's hand yeah so they're going
to be on the left side of the screen
the president
but before we go to the man dancing you
know the thing that gets me on this clip
that oh man it just makes me feel good
so good inside that there's a bunch of
hate Watchers last night that were
watching this a lot of them not watching
but there are a lot of hate Watchers
that watch last night and when they
announced the president United States
and it's Joe Biden walks out not Donald
Trump I'm just saying oh yeah that makes
me Donald Trump and Mar-A-Lago being
like oh we're going to show you how he
reacted
foreign
[Music]
delusional but uh let's go to the Matt
gets engine
[Applause]
there's the guy there's the guy with the
glasses boom same same over same look
that what's with the what's with the the
glasses you know the guy the people who
who say don't wear a mask on the house
floor and this guy's gotta so that his
glasses don't oh actually I stand
corrected so you see this body on the
right this head that's George Santos
oh so right here is George Santos yeah
because this seems like this is Steve
scalise here yep yeah I mean this is
this is the Godfather gang that
whispered in Matt gants here to get him
to change his not changes vote but to to
to to to make sure other people change
their vote yeah to lock down his guards
um because he because he gave a he gave
a vote of of uh and not voting I think
it's how he changed his Vote or present
yeah so here we go
here it is hey hey oh no that didn't you
show him shaking my dad's hand oh it
that was it that was it
uh okay so basically after the after
this moment and I'm having a hard time
finding on C-Span itself like on the
website because it just starts from
where a speech is
but basically what happens is he says
you know he has this moment and
literally right after that moment where
he bends over and shakes his hand
he
looks at Joe Biden and goes oh oh and
then gets mad Gates Matt Gates comes
over from like two seats over and comes
in it with a smile on his face shakes
the hand it's like oh yeah yeah yeah
boom Joe Biden keeps walking Anthony
devolder Anthony Santos George Santos
Anthony zabrovsky guitar ravage whatever
his name is never gets
the shake never guess he gets [__]
ignored Joe Biden goes here Joe Biden
goes there Joe Biden season walks past
and that's how it goes oh poor poor
Georgie poor Georgie the American people
were
um subjected to a lot of things last
night but this is one of them you
pointed out did the airbags oh my God
no [__] did the airbags on Garrison's
Cinema's outfit deployed during the
State of the Union
I mean it looks like the side airbags
went off oh my God I also I also said I
also said uh she was from I did it from
the what was that account because like
I'll throw a tweet in from there I said
that she was wearing uh one of Tucker
Carlson's old bow ties yeah I I thought
it might have been you but I couldn't
remember I saw that that comment I
mentioned it in the first 30 minutes
listen I don't again I don't know
fashion and maybe this is a hip cool
outfit I don't know this ain't the Met
Gala this ain't the Grammys I don't well
I mean clearly clearly there's two
people in the room that wore outfits to
make sure they got on social media
clearly there were two people and it was
Kirsten Cinema and Marjory Taylor green
can you pull up can you pull up a clip
of her of her outfit or in some pictures
of it maybe and some because I think she
even made a video afterwards in the
outfit yeah I even did a tweet about it
because a lot of people a lot of people
are they compare like a like a baboon or
something but really it's Cruella
Deville to me like she these two dressed
up in like
cartoonish evil villain costumes just to
get on social media uh it was it was
something I don't it's I'll find the
video but this is the I took a clip of
it and then I just had a little little
context to it is this the um that her
her take after
this is Walt this is mid while she's
yelling it's just a it's a screenshot
but I'll give you a nice second okay
okay so here is um here's Gabe's tweet
of the the screenshot before the State
of Union Marge oh damn it audition to be
the Russian villain in the next Bond
movie however after casting calling
called to tell her she didn't get the
part she yelled at liar
I mean man you don't get
what you did can you get more
stereotypical than this this is crazy
[__] look at that I mean the idea all
she's missing is a bottle of [__]
Stoli dude like some caviar some Stoli
and her name's Natasha and she's like uh
I'm Natasha what is nice
what is crazy
runs around acting like the Democrats
are elitist
um you know making fun of you know like
elitist things that they do and here
she's dressed in this outfit for the
State of the Union again knowing that
she's gonna be on social media that's
where she that's why she wore this
outfit
um also by the way when she was leaving
her office that day with the balloon
because I want to show the balloon uh oh
yeah here's the um here's here's a video
from Asin of Biden during the speech
getting some reactions and then getting
her her yelling you lie or you lie Liars
yeah I think she said I think another
person that I saw online said that she
said lies lies and then she says liar
right but I think she even booed him at
one point yeah I mean like sporting if
you're gonna [__] say something if
you're gonna belt out some word don't
say something that's already been said
to Obama right and that's kind of like
if anyone remembers the you lie moment
you lie
that was kind of the first time someone
had ever like
like rebelled against uh a state of the
union and at that point it was like oh
that's disrespectful and even
Republicans were like yeah it wasn't the
time or the place and now they even
reprimanded that person yeah and now
it's commonplace right they go oh well
yeah you can Boone you can cheer and you
can do this you could yell out you can
say [__] you you can say you're a
traitor you can say you're a liar and no
one will do anything Kevin McCarthy sits
there and goes yeah well and and here's
what I'll tell you is the the comparison
the contrast from the time that it
happened with Obama the famous moment
and then now is Obama at the at that
point because it was so out of the
ordinary he turns and he points and he's
like you shut the [__] up right no I'm
serious that's kind of I mean come on
that's I mean and I'm surprised Obama
didn't say hey you shut the [__] up you
know like like I'm surprised you know
because he he says the word [__] that's
what I liked about Obama the most and he
he used the word [__] if you use the
word [__] you're supposed to be more
intelligent so it makes me highly
indulgent I guess I don't know but
here's the their difference is Joe Biden
in this clip you're gonna see it he
doesn't get [__] mad he doesn't get
[__] upset there's no visceral
reaction on his party's like yeah I
expect these clowns to be clowns like
that's what they are I mean they're
[__] idiots they're children of
course they're gonna act like children
but watch the moment here
so my many some of my Republican friends
want to take the economy hostage I get
it unless I agree to their economic
plans
all of you at home should know what
those plans are
instead of making the wealthy pay their
fair share some Republicans some
Republicans want Medicare and Social
Security Sunset I'm not saying it's a
majority
now if you if you look here you see way
up here in the back
and they made sure to put Corella
DeVille I mean Marge in the back because
the probably the way she was [__]
dressed
um yeah they're like whoa whoa
abominable snowman just came in whoa
whoa what blizzard did you just come
from whoa heyo are you coming from
Antarctica on an expedition what the
[__] going on well mother of Russia
it's really cold
Russia so um
oh so rat and Rasputin's girlfriend here
um
what
you didn't know I could reference it so
here so here is that's good that's good
here's here's uh Sasquatch all right
excuse me ask what I mean Marge back
here and no that's that's Madison
cawthorne oh yeah [__] he's he's asking
we're double dipping on the nickname no
we can't do it no she's she's the
wannabe Yeti yeah so the uh the yeti
from something she changed her outfit
earlier from the wish.com version of
Pennywise right into the wannabe Bond
villain right for people who don't like
people dressing up in costumes and
Performing she really did dress up in
several costumes yesterday and performed
but let's watch her performance here
because I think it zooms in
action
contact my office
and there it is there she is there's the
close-up I just love the fact that he's
like if anyone disagrees contact my
office right call me [__] dial those
digits and like prove me wrong right you
[__] scambags and of course she's
proving him right in the moment right I
mean this is what this is proving him
right in the moment
just because of her vile reaction
towards this let's let's continue copy
you lie she says
that means Congress doesn't vote
so they're at the end that was at the
end um but I'll give it the freeze frame
here
um where she says that's right before
she says liar yeah
because she's sitting down at that point
I don't know who she's sitting next to
but she's in the very very back the
petty Yeti that's it
Roderick Berry thank you very much for
the petty Yeti I think Roderick is the
one who who coined the [__] committees
here on the podcast so if it is Roderick
if it was you I believe it was
a double
um if you ever if if a petty Yeti but
post that from the podcast account and
give Roderick uh some credit there on
YouTube yeah Petty Yeti that is perfect
thank you Roderick
um for the layup there for us uh on the
nickname of the petty Yeti that's pretty
damn good
um let's show the moment where uh the
petty Yeti decided to dress up as
Pennywise
hey hey Roderick get on it we need a
good name a nickname for it for
Pennywise too so uh if you're if you're
working out there
yep I thought so thank you Roderick
thank you Roderick stay stay with the
nicknames in the chat if I catch them
we'll try that we'll try to get him get
it going Roger do you do you have a do
you have a Twitter handle so I can yeah
yeah if you got a Twitter Channel put
put it in the chat so we can give you
credit on Twitter if not we'll just say
uh on YouTube chat um on the show
um let me see if I can find the maybe
it's under Pennywise
um
oh Pennywise is trending of course yeah
um Yep this yours is TR hey Gabe yours
is at the very top so I I search
Pennywise
so I searched Pennywise here because
it's trending and Gabe Sanchez is number
one under the Pennywise Trend Eat Your
Heart Out Elon Musk um you said Mary
Taylor green is the wish version of
Pennywise with a clown Emoji
um and here is here's the videotape is
this the is this her official tape or
did you like dub over it or something uh
no this is the one I didn't want to I
didn't want to do hers uh but Patriot
takes took it from okay okay so this is
a this is a a retweet of their video
okay let's watch
foreign
every time Roderick Petty wise
the petty Yeti and Petty wise thank you
Roderick see it was right there it was
right there in front of me the whole
time so I appreciate it did he did he
get a did he get a uh I don't I don't
unless I don't I don't know I want to
follow you on Twitter uh rhetoric if you
if you put your Twitter handle on there
I'll follow you and really
um also if we can get his YouTube
YouTube if he's got movies I'll
subscribe to his YouTube channel and you
should subscribe to our YouTube channel
yeah well why we're talking about it why
we're talking about it there's a lot of
people here on the broadcast you might
as well go subscribe to detoni Michael's
podcast so if you're on YouTube right
now subscribe if you're not we're almost
to 14 000. I know where we're at right
now we're almost to 14 000 on the road
to twenty to help us out we're like less
than 100 or we're this morning but let's
watch the rest of pennywise's petty
Eddie walk here
foreign
that she put out yes yes it is the
footage that she put out again no not
again but I mean again no and again yes
no it's one of those things that
Republicans they think that they're
being clever or they think that they're
being funny or they think that they've
got a good joke or they know the punch
line but they don't see Republicans
conservatives Maga how they work is they
think that anything they do is is funny
right and they think that any
any kind of malicious or hateful thing
that they say and they're like oh that's
a joke and you're just getting upset
because you don't get it you know and
that's not the case the fact is that
you're [__] dumb and the joke doesn't
land because it's not a joke there
wasn't a sale or the punchline
they are the joke the fact that so many
people uh took this this whole video
they took a screenshot of a photo that
she had of her with the balloon they
wrote it on it they wrote uh some other
stuff on the balloon itself and like the
It font
um
I saw a couple people that had redone uh
uh politics uh I had a version that she
was actually Pennywise holding the
balloon so I've seen some pretty pretty
clever stuff but what ends up happening
is these idiots think they're making a
[__] joke but they just make a joke
of themselves because they set everyone
up
to make the punch line they like they
deliver the joke right before and then
you're like oh this is the wish version
of Pennywise oh here here is Pennywise
with the balloon here's Petty wise with
the balloon yeah here's this here's that
they set everyone up for everyone to
[__] spike the ball down and that's
what it is and they don't have any jokes
because they're the joke itself
they are the joke that's why they're so
hard to parody because they really are
the joke they are the joke and if you
look here even more of a joke
if you look here in the background
because they always accuse Democrats of
colluding with the media well she's
banging the media like literally she's
[__] a dude from Newsmax what's his
name what's this guy's name I don't know
some mediocre white man right now right
he's just an old white nut sack and
she's actually banging him they're
having an affair that's why one of the
reasons why her husband's divorcing her
I think that's the that's the talk I
don't [__] know one of the reasons
allegedly she's been marked down by a
lot of guys I think I mean allegedly
Marjorie Taylor green had an affair with
Alex Stein what about Matt yes that's
what was that was there that was another
one that says someone I mean like baked
Alaska who we just watched earlier this
week go to prison surrender himself to a
low Security federal prison in Florida
for his involvement in the Insurrection
on January 6th
he said because Marjorie if I don't know
if people remember this during the whole
Kanye Nick Fuentes situation Marjorie
Taylor green went after Nick Fuentes so
as a result baked Alaska went after
Margaret Taylor green for going after
Nick Fuentes I mean [__] cannibalism
here and then what ends up happening is
he says oh yeah Marjorie Taylor green
actually slept with uh Alex Stein and
then Alex I was like that never happened
you know it's like I don't know man I
don't know I don't know I'm gonna
believe the worst here all right here's
uh here's apparently a picture of petty
wise
um after she walked down the hall
um Paul gave us this um this
piece of Journalism here so I retweeted
I think it's true I don't know I mean
allegedly that's what she looked like
what am I supposed to do uh I mean I see
a photo of it now so now I have to
believe well you know the other thing
too is like the the whole Pennywise
thing her costume was much much worse
than her her Petty Yeti costume or Petty
Eddie I mean the petty Eddie was on
point she really really I mean like I
said she was auditioning for the role of
a new Bond villain in the next uh next
film unfortunately she didn't get it but
right unfortunately I don't know maybe
she would have made a great Bond villain
or maybe she would have been one of
those villains that you'd find on some
straight to DVD movie that like gives a
huge monologue and explains their plan
only to then be killed by their own plan
kind of thing you know like the the the
the the protagonist just sits there and
is like I'll just let the antagonist of
this film just
kill themselves
speaking of horrible Bond villains
I mean just horrible Bond villains this
[__] guy just can't quit making me
laugh oh this Cliff is hilarious and I
know a lot of you were like oh my God
you're giving him a platform guys listen
listen he's the former president United
States He is the candidate for the
Republican party yeah he has only one
he's gonna be the nominee he's gonna
he's running for president he's gonna
run against Joe Biden on that
platforming him I'm just [__] mocking
and making fun of him showing you at a
mock and make fun of him in front of his
[__] supporters so they'll be
embarrassed I mean I know they have no
shame but maybe the ones that you find
that have just a hint just the shred
just a [__] dingleberry of Shame left
uh on them maybe they'll they'll change
their minds but this
this is this is some class a delusion
Gabe Sanchez oh it is [__] well let's
listen here's the real State of the
Union
just the first line is let me tell you
the real estate of the Union
uh
Twitter like I don't know what he's
gonna say because I haven't really
watched this thing I just read I haven't
watched the video all I did was read the
post that he made last night which was
kind of in a weird way congratulating
Joe Biden it's kind of weird it's weird
I don't know well the other thing that's
funny about this is this is a minute and
50 seconds so literally the the
president United States even when he was
faking and pretending to be president of
the United States he would give a state
of the union that was like an hour long
but he he says this is the real State of
the Union and it's a minute it's a
minute 50 seconds like what the [__] how
are you gonna do the real estate Union
in a minute even Sarah I could be
Sanders spoke more than a minute 50
seconds I mean by speak I mean puke up
vile into a microphone but you know what
I'm talking about but here's the thing
is that again the difference between Joe
Biden's speech and previous speeches
that Trump has given but this one in
particular you know Joe Biden says we US
America we US America the country the
American people we us this guy's like I
me Trump
it's hilarious let's watch over the past
two years undivided millions and
millions of illegal aliens from 160
different countries have stormed across
our Southern border drug cartels are now
raking in billions of dollars
from smuggling poison to kill our people
and to kill our children
Savage Killers rapists and violent
criminals are being released from jail
he's back on the old train remember when
he came down because I know you talked
about this moment a lot and when he came
down the escalator and he got and he
announced for president and he's like
they're they're sitting they're not
sinning their best
rapists like he's like all back in he's
like he's like they're not all that
he's really leaning into his
announcement when he ran in 2016 and he
also uses like do you guys remember that
time when I went down the escalator and
I gave that speech that was pretty
xenophobic racist and hateful yeah let's
do that again let's continue to continue
their crime wave and unto Biden the
murder rate has reached the highest
in the history of our country
Biden and the radical Democrats have
wasted trillions of dollars and caused
the worst inflation in half a Century
Real which again Biden pointed out last
night that hey the facts are is that you
actually piled on 25 of our national
debt that we have now was all piled on
in your four years under Trump and by
the way inflation has gone down the last
six months and it continues to go down
in this objections was it 1.3 or 1.4
trillion that Joe Biden has helped
reduce
Democrats always reduce the national
debt Obama did it Clinton did it Biden
almost like yeah there are social and
government programs re-initiatives know
that Democrats
introduce to actually are you sure help
like they like it's almost like they
deliver
this has got to be fake news this has
got to be real man I don't know but then
you have Kevin McCarthy was like Joe
Biden increased the national debt by 800
billion no it actually reduced it by 1.4
trillion [__] right but you know
the facts don't like your feelings Kevin
McCarthy or Trump they faxed it not
participate and also he did it he did it
in less time
then then Trump was in office all right
yeah right half the time yeah half the
time let's let's listen wages are down
21 months in a row gas prices have
stored and are now going up much higher
than even before and the typical
American family is paying 2 200 in
increased energy and food costs each
year Joe Biden's weaponized justice
department and I'm a victim of it I'm a
victim
you're coming after you but mainly me
I'm a victim yes I might have done
something illegal
I can't even believe he says in the
first line the real State of the Union
is I am a victim like literally that's
how we need to we need to cut it we need
to cut the this clip the real estate
Union is I am a victim
oh my God he says it out loud like how
do you people who support this fool not
know that he's got you fooled you know
what's you know what's funny is oh
there's a lot but yeah I mean the whole
thing is the whole thing is [__]
ridiculous it's like [__] the the
groundhog came out last week and we're
still living in six million more years
of what the [__] is going on
um but you look at you look at the
actual video that um
uh that he posted on this video that he
posted on Truth social and the overlay
that he has on the screen is him
giving the State of the Union when he
was president
and it's like that's the time is the
thumbnail that's the thumbnail yeah if
you hear I'll send you the yeah yeah
send me send me that link you know I
wanna I wanna go back because I know the
producers of this content have been
watching and listening and they've been
taking our critiques so I want to take a
minute here to say you know you've done
a good job up to this point but your
lighting is way off on this video it's
almost like you guys Rush yeah yeah you
you [__] you [__] him on the whole
orange thing because I know he's
obsessed with not looking Orange from
that documentary footage we're like do I
look orange do I look do I look orange
is it why is it orange give me the cup
movie the table okay only the cup no
table what
but d looks really Orange in this one
yeah he looks pretty I think they would
have caught that in the production but I
guess they rushed to get it out you know
right they're real they're like okay
we're just gonna they're like we're just
gonna riff this one through all right
sir please get your pants back on uh
We're not gonna see him but we we just
for the sake of filming we don't want to
see that right it's a distraction right
do you because when are you supposed to
like do live commentary as the uh any
what is he a [__] ringside
commentator I don't know I thought he
was supposed to do some kind of go look
at his true Social account I think he
announced that he was going to do some
kind of play-by-play and literally I
think that's what he said play by play
of the stadium 13 hours ago which is
hilarious yeah it was yesterday sometime
after the show he was like play by play
I'm gonna be Joe batting
um let's see
what the words out try try to find that
and I'll play the rest this way you're
looking for the play-by-play thing is
persecuting his political opponents his
administration is Waging War and Free
Speech they're trying to indoctrinate
and mutilate our children he's leading
us to the brink of World War III and on
top of all of that that he's the most
corrupt president in American history
and it's not even close but the good
news he's nowhere close to as corrupt as
me I mean I'm way less corrupt I'm the
least corrupt president of all time this
is so stupid everyone knows this is all
projection especially when he says I'm
the victim yeah in the speech I'm okay I
just want to let you know I'm scrolling
through uh truth social right now and
I've already I mean I've called these
ads out multiple times
but let me tell you if there is a
problem with with seeing an ad that says
you know truth ads sponsored by truth
Cheaper Than Dirt I don't know if that's
actually the uh the name did you know
did you know dirt is actually really
expensive real estate is really
expensive it is it is but it says
Cheaper Than Dirt there's no spaces
there's a ctd that's Capital C capital T
capital D exclamation point so the
currenting is off and the space is off
it's time to upgrade your rifle pay
later with credova shop rifles and then
I don't want to click this link but I'm
sure it'll take me to go buy some guns
uh it's got a disassembled rifle on here
but this is in between a thing that says
he's got one tweet that says Joe's the
one who destroyed the supply chain now
he's talking about how to rebuild it
rifle ad and then he's got one that just
showed swallow a man who spent a lot of
time in spy Fang Fang's honey net
wasn't removed from our most important
committee only in America so he was live
truthing it yeah he was live truth in it
uh I mean
just Christ I can't believe how horrible
that that how why they named it that and
why they did that and it's so ridiculous
but I I he wasn't all he he goes Kevin
McCarthy who is a great guy is having a
seriously hard time staying awake I give
him credit for being true to himself and
the cause he is just not interested in
what is being fed to the audience
god dude this is [__] crazy
well let's let's continue with this
crazy maybe we'll go to that crazy if we
got time news is we are going to reverse
every single crisis Calamity and
disaster that Joe Biden has created
I am running for president to end the
destruction of our country and to
complete the unfinished business of
making America great again we will make
our country better than ever before and
we will always put America first I I
thought it was I thought it was the best
it could ever be be under him so how
could he be better than ever before and
one again it's again it's like how do
you make something great again if it was
great when you made it great and again
and again and again so you got a lot of
um um links here which which one the
first the first one's the tweet
that's a nickname tweet so I just wanted
to share that I didn't I didn't cat I
might have missed if if uh Roderick had
a a handle but I
I shared it on the the Pod account oh
okay yeah yeah you can see the petty
Yeti here's the uh here's the credit
thanks Roderick the petty Yeti rhetoric
Berry the petty
Eddie she will be she is no longer
Marjorie hoodfoot green she is the petty
Yeti so thank you rhetoric for your
contribution again again because we
might get to the [__] committees today
Roderick I don't know though we're
we're tough on time see this is why we
need three hours but um
yeah justify this [__] oh man we really
need like 12 hours a day let's be honest
if I had more time in a day I would but
okay so this is um what is this is this
this is the video but I just wanted to
show this is the same video we watched
oh okay yeah I'm just showing you the
the overlay that they have this is like
the thumb beginning
where it's he speaks I mean this yeah
this is how it begins but yeah but it's
him speaking State of the Union
here's the real State of the Union
sorry just I had to play that one more
time where's the real State of the Union
State of the Union look I'm the
president the military and Michael
Jackson and JFK Jr told me so this is
what they do okay so what is this that
you sent me this is thank you
um what's this
uh this is just a post that I saw in
there that I thought was so ridiculous
so if you go to the this one don't wait
wait scroll down to the meme itself okay
their first mistake was overestimating
themselves their second mistake was
underestimating Trump and it's Trump
next to a [__] lion well you know
what the line is right
is what just the the king of the jungle
is the is not right well right but they
use these Christian [__] use that lion
as a symbol like right I guess I don't
know I don't know I mean I think that's
what that's what the it's the Q Anon
it's the Q Anon thing yeah yeah yeah for
Christianity but um of course they clap
they go clap clap clap clap clap and
then Trump trump
fraud socials it he says thank you but
we have a lot to work to do we are a
nation in Decline Maga
I ape I thought you fixed this country
to be yeah and you only needed four
years and only you could do it I would
like to know
how what it was that was so great I mean
we were in a pandemic uh we had a lot of
social injustices that we had to uh we
had to support and and actually
represent despite the fact that you all
thought everyone was a [__] Thug
Trump
it's just like I don't know man yeah
well I want to show you one really
shitty response
to the um Biden stated Union last night
this is a horrible one by the way oh
nice horrible too so it's a good one oh
it's a good one yeah it's hilarious it's
hilarious and I feel like my response to
it was pretty I was pretty good at this
response when I saw this tweet I came up
with this right away and had to tweet it
out
um can you pull up though the clip of
Sarah Huckabee Sanders talking about
um the culture War I just want I just
want that that clip I don't want the
whole thing I want to listen that [__]
just the clip where she's blaming her
racist rant right well I mean we ain't
got enough time we got 10 minutes left I
want to get to the [__] committees where
Jim Jordan gets his ass stuffed in the
trash if we can but that just a clip of
Sarah Huckabee Sanders talking about how
the culture wars is liberals fault but
here's here's one take on Biden's uh
from Matt Walsh you guys know Matt
Walsh's
um he's the one who makes videos about
underage children really weird obsessed
hyper focused videos about underage
children Matt Walsh says Biden's habit
of randomly screaming for no discernible
reason is a classic symptom of
Alzheimer's okay
so I guess he's talking about when
Biden's trying to speak over the crowd
yeah when they're yelling and he's
trying to speak over Republicans or
maybe he's talking about how Grandpa
poopy pants the Cheeto desk you and
honor yells in his true social post I'm
not really sure which one he's talking
about but he was my response my response
Matt Walsh's habit of being hyper
focused on underage children is a
classic symptom of pedophilia uh you
should check that out Matt go check out
the the classic symptoms of pedophilia
maybe we should get Matt Walsh's laptop
that's all I'm saying that's all I'm
saying speaking of laptops
where you're still trying to find that I
want to play this moment because I want
to make sure this gets played
um today and why we still have time this
has really nothing to do with the State
of the Union other than it's Jim I don't
report sex Rhymes Jordan getting stuffed
in the trash and any moment that I can
show of this guy absolutely getting
owned a cell phone mainly is worth it
um and this comes from Aaron Rupert uh
he says rep Gary Connolly after Jim
Jordan flails around for about five
minutes because he does this whole
diatrad about Hunter Biden's lamp top
and Twitter files and he's trying to go
out after Joel Roth who used to work for
Twitter that he was threatened because
Elon Musk basically called him a
pedophile on Twitter
um with his Twitter files his former
employee by the way which Joel Roth
should sue the absolute [__] out of
Twitter and Elon Musk I don't know if he
is but he should see the [__] out of him
I mean for like 44 billion just take
Twitter away from him well you can't sue
a company like that you can sue
individuals because that's the whole
thing of like tech companies are
protected to say like oh we we I think
okay well Sue Elon [__] him right yeah I
mean yeah Sue Elon for sure and really
the the American people should if they
can support him in his legal cost to do
that just just for the [__] pure
principle of it like hey we know you're
not going to win but let's just do this
thing for the American people and yo
Roth after what Elon did to this
[__] but anyways
um In This Moment sorry as I'm searching
for this there's so many clips of uh
Sarah Huckabee Sanders which part do you
want the one where she talks about the
it's it's the liberals who want the
culture wars we never wanted we are
under attack in a left-wing culture War
yeah I think so yeah that's yeah so give
me that one that's the one I want
um but here's why why we're waiting on
that club here's the one of Jim Jordan
oh God this is hilarious this is great
watch this is this a violation of the
first amendment when the government Mr
Chan again sending you an email saying
we think these accounts them with their
stupid [__] headline of the New York
Post in the background why do they think
that the tabloids is evidence in a
Committee hearing because that's how it
all that's how everyone knows the story
so they're like oh the time that they
blocked a new your post and suppress the
Free Press from actually talking about
the story
about it right but the only evidence
that they're presenting is the evidence
of Twitter files that that clearly shows
the fact that Hunter Biden's [__]
pictures of his dick on their platform
or against their terms of service
someone reported it and they took them
down yeah what why what is so
controversial about this if someone took
pictures of your dick and posted them on
Twitter without your consent you could
report them and they would be taken down
what the [__] is so controversial about
that yeah anybody can report any tweet
they want this isn't [__] abnormal
that the that the Biden campaign
reported these tweets it's not rocket
science but you know it is Jim Jordan so
you didn't understand that let's keep
going here counts need to be looked at
because they violate your terms of
service that's a different standard so
you got the government saying your terms
of service which don't have to comply
with the First Amendment but the
government's saying we don't think these
accounts comply with your terms of
service please take them down the the
first amendment is for the person's
terms of service that they own
Twitter has the freedom of speech with
their terms of service you dumb
[__] this is the stupidest thing
I've ever heard of and really honestly
this is one thing that Joe Biden
mentioned last night that I actually
believe I truly do believe that in this
Congress there is a situation that I
could see coming out of the house a bill
to check social media because because
Republicans pretend to hate big tech and
as long as they pretend to hate big Tech
maybe there could be a bill that could
work out in the favor of the American
people for so I mean you if you uh if
anyone remembers from last night Joe
Biden did call out things that actually
got you know Republicans be like oh yo
yeah okay over for that and one of those
things was I look at [__] Paul gosar
by the way
um one of the things he just looks like
he's [__] are you alive he looks like
he's alive and then he's just sleeping
over there but uh Joe Biden last night
mentioned you know that the negative
impacts that big Tech and social media
have on specifically younger kids young
children right and said he's like I
don't want collecting data you know I
don't collect data experiment on kids
through different you know programs that
they have and Republicans were like oh
[__] uh okay I guess we agree with that
one too there were a couple moments
there was the there was the fentanyl
moment there was uh the big Tech uh you
know Pharma stuff like that like it was
moments where they they they were locked
in and they were in agreement with what
he said because you know he does he does
have ground for what he's talking about
but it was interesting to see like at
some points Republicans like yeah okay
yeah we do that so who knows I mean
they're trying to ban Tick-Tock and
whole states across the country right
well we'll see what the federal
government has moved to ban tick tock on
government devices right which I kind of
agree with I don't think think we should
be scared of tick tock America
um you know but but you know a lot of
people are frightened by it which you
know I I get the argument yeah but but
whether it's a Chinese organization or
American organization they're gonna get
your data okay
um but let's watch The Exchange here
with uh Jim Jordan but more about the
response from Connolly of Jim Jordan's
rant let's watch it
you see a problem there Mr Mr Roth
Mr chairman I'm seeing a flashing red
light I'm happy to answer the question
um do I think that that's a valuable use
of the FBI's time no but I don't see in
a request for review a problem under the
First Amendment no I sure do I I thank
the gentleman you bet
so the entire time he did this whole
thing to get yeah you brought up the
thing he brought up the email to prove
that just asking for a company a private
company to review something that had
been shared or posted on that private
company's platform saying hey can you
can I'm requesting that you just review
this Jim Jordan believes that goes
against our First Amendment right right
no because what the FBI wanted to know
is if it was criminal right you [__]
boneheads they wanted to know if what
was happening was criminal it's a
private company
they can make whatever rules and
guidelines they want because it's their
first amendment not the government the
government an agency that they
contracted to go through and help them
to help fight disinformation around the
covid uh the election you know things
that would help especially if there was
Russian interference
they asked them and they said hey I hope
or not they said like you know we want
to work together the easiest path
forward is that you agree to work with
us and we don't have to like come in and
subpoena stuff we would rather that you
guys and Twitter also agreed we as
Twitter would rather our team because we
have the actual
uh uh level of like hierarchy and and
who can see things in Access
instead of giving it over to some
government agency we will take the
request in and we will review it
internally in our private company right
with our infrastructure and you have to
pay us to do that work right here's
here's the risk
oh my God this is this is great so Jim
Jordan's gonna yield back his time here
chair recognize Mr Conley for five
minutes thank you Mr chairman
what happens when you hold a hearing and
you can't prove your point
oh and this is I don't know if uh
Connolly had that line written for him
or had it ready but every Democrat
should have this ready every single one
I mean that's what it is these
Republicans we we saw it during Benghazi
we're gonna see it again in this attempt
to uh look into the the
um
uh the you know the investigate the
investigation the weaponization of the
federal government against certain
people you know AKA we just want to look
at the FBI and the doj looking into
Donald Trump for inciting Insurrection
and also stealing classified documents
at his home in Mar-A-Lago God forbid we
actually have Law and Order and we
investigate those who actually committed
crimes but Republicans don't want that
and so what we're going to find we're
gonna spend millions of dollars to find
out these these [__] files this [__]
committee is going to reveal that there
was no wrongdoing by Twitter it's going
to to be a nothing burger what they're
actually going to find out is that there
may have been crimes that were committed
by stealing these photos and exposing
them on Twitter right of Hunter Biden's
huge hog of his huge exposing how much
bigger Hunter Biden's dick is than Dom
Junior's I'm just saying um speaking of
I I'm a smokey eye well
I was gonna make a dick jokes
I didn't want to go there well here's
here's the official response of the um
of the Republican party I'm so surprised
that she edged in the official response
and not Trump that's probably what
pissed him off so much and that's why he
was so [__] angry in that response
but this is just a clip and this is the
one thing that I wanted to say something
about today there's so much in her
racist rant and there's so much to her
basically saying Trump should almost
step aside there's a little bit of you
know overshadowing for that
um you know because he's in this war
with DeSantis damn it we got to get to
that too uh let's play this
and while you reap the consequences of
their failures the Biden Administration
seems more interested in woke fantasies
than the hard reality Americans face
every day
most Americans simply want to live their
lives in Freedom and peace
but we are under attack in a left-wing
culture War we didn't start and never
wanted to fight get the [__] out of here
with that [__] you with your m m
genitalia and your Mr Potato Head and
your Disney is woke the [__] out of here
you people you're the ones who took this
wokism and mother wokers things to a
whole new level yeah we didn't start the
[__] levels are going to enter
people's privacy by determining what
gender they are or what sexuality they
should be or what their pronouns are or
what what they should be doing in their
own home like these are the people that
want to go into someone's house and be
like hey who said you two could have sex
that's who this party is they're the
ones who are like ah let's pull down the
pants and lift up the skirt are you
actually who you say you are underneath
that's who the Republican party is
they're the [__] freaks they're the
creeps they're the pedophiles they're
the groomers they're the sex traffickers
that actually are projecting their old
wants and desires onto other people and
then when they get called out for they
go you guys are the real people you
groomers your pedophiles just like
[__] Matt Walsh you know what who
else uh is pointing out that they're the
groomers it's like the Spider-Man meme
where their point where he's pointing
himself you said oh look groomer Trump
is fighting with groomer DeSantis and
this this folks is the most delicious
thing that happened yesterday this is so
delicious and you should lean into it on
the internet
um this photo here is of Ron DeSantis at
a party with a bunch of high scores that
he was a teacher of drinking alcohol
with him that Midas Touch exposed folks
the left-wing lyrics
2021 right two years ago two years ago
that Midas Touch exposed Ron DeSantis
for this photo and the and the photo
here now he posted several of these but
this is just one that you pulled he
posted like he was calling Ronda Santos
a pedophile over and over over and over
on social media yesterday and that's
where they're at with this war if you
don't understand what the [__] I've been
talking about when I say Donald Trump is
going to be the nominee Ronda Santos
doesn't have a chance in [__] hell
this is what I'm telling this is what
I'm talking about
Donald Trump will go to any means
necessary to destroy Ronda Santos Rhonda
Santos won't he will never he will never
stand in front of a microphone and say
any kind of groomer pedophile [__] or or
sexual assault or [__] about Trump no
[__] way no [__] how it will ruin
his political career Donald Trump not so
much he can do whatever the [__] he
wants and he's gonna do whatever the
[__] he wants to get the nomination but
you've seen how people responded online
right oh they they've well there was
different reactions but what was your
take on the the main reaction well the
main reaction is how much the
how well what's happening now
is people are now calling out Trump
for saying like oh yeah how many times
did he fly on the Loda Express or
whatever the name right Epstein
Epstein's a a plane so like now we've
got people who were Trump supporters but
are DeSantis supporters or are having a
hard time figuring out where they land
in this whole mix and now they're trying
to say oh well this guy who's calling
this other guy a groomer a pedophile
actually is or used to hang out with the
ultimate groomer and pedophile right uh
so let's pull up those receipts so it's
actually funny to see them all [__]
fighting well it's fantastic and and I I
keep telling you folks out there that
there's no better situation than Donald
Trump being their nominee it'll
guarantee that Joe Biden will be the
president for another four years
absolutely guarantee it and I would
imagine that there's going to be 12
million uh votes that are going to be
the margin between 12 to 14 million
votes that would be the margin between
Donald Trump and Joe Biden mark it down
make the time stamp you can come back
and tell me I was wrong but Donald Trump
post here not only does he repost this
picture and this meme he said that's not
Ron is it he would never do such a thing
uh and he and he's reposted this picture
of Ron DeSanto several different times
yesterday on true social this is what
I've been telling you at folks this is
what I'm telling you he's going to be
the nominee and we should [__]
encourage it we should increase
he'll get the nomination but he won't
win no that's the beautiful part of it
all and you should keep listening to
know that I am always ahead of the game
always ahead of the political game I
know what Donald Trump's gonna do before
he does it because he's predictably
unpredictable and that's why you come
here in two hours every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch make sure to get us to 14 000 I
don't know where we're at right now now
if we're we're even close but we were so
close to 14 000 this morning
um and and let's see yeah we're we're
like less than 50 away ooh subscribe to
the YouTube channel get us to 14 on our
road to 20 000 make sure to follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod go take a
look at roderick's work over there thank
you Roderick again for the new nickname
you get did the [__] committee before
the petty Yeti and Petty wise today
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify and Google make sure to follow
us on Facebook at the Tony Michaels and
go to the upwire.com the upwire.com it's
a great creators Network on YouTube go
check it out and also download the
Twitch app right now it's free you can
watch over there for free why the hell
not you should try it out over there
maybe maybe just maybe you'll like it
and if you're over there on Twitch make
sure to log in with your Amazon Prime
account you get a free subscription to
to any channel of your choice choose
ours of course
um attorney Michael's podcast but log in
with your Prime account if you can helps
us out over there on Twitch and if
you're watching on Twitch it makes it ad
free you don't have to watch any ads if
you log in with your Prime account and
use that free subscription so do that uh
Gabe dmiting what was ants coming out in
here here uh yeah I know you're working
on
uh I'm working on it what was that for a
recap of last week and stuff everything
from you know Stormy Daniels to the the
air balloon uh and then stormy Daniel
won that story like six years ago or
something oh man that was like last
Monday or Tuesday
but I know and I've I've had stuff going
on so now I'm like uh I I see people you
know I just want to say this I do see
some people that comment on the minus
touch Channel and when I post a video
I'm like oh this is old news I just want
to point out there that I'm the only one
who is writing
filming editing I'm making the graphics
I'm not I'm not The Daily Show I don't
have a team of writers or anyone who's
working maybe one of these take a little
bit of time maybe one of these days the
what was that will become you'll have a
whole staff and uh so everyone support
Gabe Sanchez and his effort for what was
that it's a great piece of content you
should support it even though sometimes
he has to to get that one last piece of
real news in the story he has to wait a
bit like he is with some of the Santos
pieces oh yeah but you should support
him because he needs that entire team of
Productions and millions of dollars to
make it The Daily Show for crying out
loud so um next week and next week I
will be officially launching uh a a uh
patreon oh great support the work that
I'm doing on what was that on what was
that and also just other eligible and
sketches and parodies and stuff like
that but but it's mainly focused around
the what was that is yeah yeah mainly
Focus around what was that
if you go support Gabe Sanchez and he'll
launch that next week if you go support
him next week maybe maybe just maybe
he'll get these things out faster he'll
be able to hire big producers and stuff
who knows you could you could make him
the new Daily Show they're looking for a
host over there I know they're going
around they got I know you know I was I
would love to play the Chelsea Handler
clip because it's [__] fantastic if
you guys haven't watched it
that's why I don't play it that's why I
don't play it because that's why I like
your what was that because we can play
it if we want right and we don't get
ding yeah dinged on the [__] on the
[__] Daily Show Daily Show lift your
goddamn copyright [__] do it so we can
play your [__] I want to play your [__]
I want to promote you for crying out
loud for free
Jesus Christ everybody same time same
place tomorrow don't miss it don't miss
it Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__]
[__] them
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn had asked Beacon